The current travels at 3 miles per hour. Excellent problem solving if you found
that answer. To solve this equation, we'll start by multiplying through by the
lowest common denominator. The LCD in this case is 12 minus x times 12 plus x
times 15. The product of all three of the denominators. So we'll multiply each
of these terms by the LCD. We'll note the factors of 12 minus x simplified in
the first fraction. 12 plus x simplifies in the second fraction. And 15
simplifies in our last fraction. Each of these reduces to 1. This leaves us
with this equation. We know 6 times 15 equals 90, so we'll change these. And
then we know this is a difference of square pattern. a minus b times a plus b.
So this will equal a squared minus b squared. 12 squared is 144. We'll have our
minus sign in between the terms, and x squared is x squared. Next we'll
distribute 90 to each of these terms. We'll distribute 90 here, and we'll
distribute positive 16 here. We get this equation, and then we want to combine
the like terms on the left. We know positive 90x, and negative 90x sum to 0.
And 1080 plus 1080 sums to 2160. And the right hand side of our equation
remains the same. Now that we have this equation, we want to try and solve for
x. Since I only have an x squared term and no other x terms, I want to move
this constant to the left hand side, and then divide through by negative 16. So
we can take the square root of both sides. We subtract 2,304 from both sides to
get negative 144 equals negative 16 x squared. Then we divide both sides by
negative 16 to get 9 is equal to x squared. We take the square root of both
sides so x can equal positive 3 or negative 3. Since x is the speed of the
current, we know that we need the positive value. x must equal 3 miles per
hour.